Iris, this feels like a good time
to get into a little family business
considering you're promoting
your family business movie, "The Bubble."
And I was wondering if you would do
a Final Five: Family Edition with me?
Of course.
All right, let's do this!
Final Five: Family Edition!
That's right, okay, number one,
who is most like to forget their lines on set?
Me.
(Drew laughing)
Okay, who is the funniest,
your sister, your mom or your dad?
Who cracks you up the most?
My sister, for sure.
Ah.
Yeah, she's pretty funny.
Okay, who is most likely to spill a secret?
Maude Apatow.
Interesting.
She like has no.
I call her the town yeller,
because she literally tells everybody
anything that I say to her, which is you know.
Okay, I love this.
It also strikes a good chord for sisterhood.
Who has the biggest potty mouth of the family?
My dad.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Okay, which parent is most likely to lay down that law?
My mom, for sure.
She's strict when she needs to be,
and I definitely needed it at points, like for sure.
She's very strict,
but she knows exactly what she's talking about
and she's always right.
So I definitely appreciate it,
I need it.
Well, I love you, I love your family.
I'm so happy for this really awesome, fun movie.
You can watch "The Bubble,"
streaming on Netflix starting April 1st.
And I just, really I do,
I love you, Iris, I love your family,
and you've made the world a better place honestly,
with all of my heart.
I'm so happy to be here.
Thank you.
It's so true.
(upbeat music)